[Music]
you seem like a very placid easygoing
guy but i do i'm i'm told you yourself
have had some anger issues um i yeah i
get a little i've been i've just started
trans mental meta transcendental
meditation i can't even say it yet um
and that's calming me down a bit i just
i have
it's mostly in the car like
laurel canyon you know there's a road
it's getting very specific it's very
very specific yeah there's a road laurel
canyon it goes over a hill and at the
top of the canyon you is a mole holland
drive everyone's heard of that so
it's a two-lane road but there's a very
clear sign halfway up the road that if
you are in the right lane you have to
turn right well people don't do that
here they tried to wait to the very end
and then cut you off but they will not
do that to me they will not do that to
me i will drive you
off the mountain into the dog park oh
wow if you try to get in front you know
i know
they know miles down
then it's not too late there's a long
line there's a long line of people did
you think that you were special i don't
understand these people's sleep yes yes
i you know i heard this was something
that you bugged you i had a diagram made
of what people do because this bugs me
yes you have to if you're gonna get this
turn right that's a solid line yes okay
i carry this with me because it makes me
angry too
and this is you in this car right here
and this guy goes rocketing everyone's
gonna lie in there
[Applause]
you feel better to get that out
incredible i have the same way i'm just
screaming
it's that irish rage i don't know what
it is it's irish rage irish rape blame
that on my mother
i blame it on my mother and i am 110
higher so i can't pick one parent uh
okay uh character traits from real life
uh you i'm told that you used some of
your character traits from real life uh
in your on the show your character on
the show and i'm curious uh because when
i watch the show and i talk to you in
person i don't know exactly what the
traits you're talking about like what do
you borrow from real life that you use
on the show um when i get scared i
become
very effeminate i
i get scared easily like i said i am my
mother-son so i feel like like for
example when i'm on a plane you know
when you get on a plane and you hit that
first pocket of turbulence
and you hear that person in the back
that person that does that yeah and you
turn your feet like oh my god i hope
she's gonna be okay yeah yeah yeah i'm
the she i'm the lady
i mean and we i mean i don't like
animals and they're constantly making me
work with like birds on the show and
things like that like i get afraid there
was a i was living in brooklyn with my
wife one time and we were we had windows
that opened up sideways and one morning
i hear
and i i opened the curtain back and
there's a baby bird about this big
sitting there it was caught
i threw my wife
towards the bird and jumped over the bed
in the outside closed the doors like you
gotta get out of there
you gotta get out
it's gonna get you would have thought a
bald eagle was in the room
yeah
i lose my mind yeah yeah
that's how i
getting it out yeah at least it doesn't
happen when you're angry or else you'll
be on mulholland
you stop it don't you merge
[Laughter]